hello everyone i would like to preface
this interview by saying something very
important
that i know is a fundamental upstream
solution
which will solve many of our downstream
issues
many of us are wondering how can we
optimize civilization's
sense making what kind of communications
architectures are optimal to catalyze
love wisdom harmony and sustainable
growth the answer
that you'll find in this episode is
simply
emotionally intelligent conversation
by giving david the space to express his
world view we together came up with
excellent solutions for sense-making on
the topic
there was no name-calling there was no
yelling
there was no anger there was no ego
there was just genuine authentic sincere
inquiry into perspective
you'll find us uncover and strategize on
two solutions to how we can make sense
on this topic as a civilization i will
go ahead and explain them here because
they fascinate me
and can help us harmonize as a society
flat earth cartography has antarctica
as an outer ring surrounding the
continents
there have been efforts from independent
teams to explore this but they
have not come to fruition
in creating two business models around
antarctica tourism
we can quickly provide all humans that
are
interested with the front row seat to
experiential
knowledge of the truth of our home
number one flights over antarctica
from south america to australia from
south africa to new zealand
how fun would it be to have david weiss
on a plane with neil degrasse tyson
and an unbiased film crew number two
ships cruise around antarctica with
the shoreline in sight
cruise around it yourself or
have a loved one and you take two boats
to cruise around it and meet
there are already some projects which
are actualizing these goals
there are always empathetic wise
loving scientific experiential
upstream solutions it is
up to us to be intelligent enough to
identify these
and implement them this
sense making synchronicity was recorded
on the winter solstice
all life is beautiful art
develop the faculties to see it
enjoy the episode